to pretend not to notice People's race
day hey you seen Reggie around which one
is Reggie oh uh well today he's wearing
yellow pants uh yellow shirt yellow hat
yellow shoes uh he's got a gold tooth uh
diamond earring um he's got that big
necklace with a dollar sign on it uh
he's always grabbing his crotch when
he's telling a story like the one about
when he found out his mother is really
his grandmother would you be more
specific uh oh let's see uh he always
wears cheap cologne uh drives him
Mercury Cougar with a crown on the
dashboard uh never Pays His alimony uh
he's extremely cut for a guy who never
works out oh there he is thanks anyway
hey
Reggie you see there at the end it kind
it inverts your expectations what were
you thinking H I wasn't thinking
anything